I thought this was a really cool part of
your journal
that you wrote and you're talking about
getting through that kind of stuff so
here we go back to the journal it is
easy to be motivated to succeed in the
beginning of an endeavor and when you
are close to the end the most difficult
part and the part where people quit is
when they are in the thick of it and it
is unclear whether they have the
strength and stamina to make it the rest
of the way while I never actually
doubted my ability to walk again during
my recovery I am certainly subject to
the inner monologue rationalizing why it
is okay to quit or to not push myself to
the goal that I have written down on
paper one way I have recognized to aid
in shutting that monologue the fuck up
is celebrating milestones the hardest
part of working toward a goal is when we
are either making slow progress or
negative progress and having the
patience and confidence to know that the
improvements we make over the long
periods as opposed to the short periods
are what matter milestones are what
remind us that we are making progress
even if it isn't apparent every day in
rowing I've heard of people that count
strokes until the finish line using sets
of 10 personally I like to count to 50s
for making up a race when I ran the
nation's triathlon I picked points ahead
of me to make it to and when I got there
I'd pick a new point anything we can use
to keep our minds from succumbing to the
monologue will work not only ensure
short-term goals but also in long-term
goals like graduating from college or
learning to use prosthetics great advice
for anybody to pay attention to